just like the Jerry Jones thing where
somebody out of nowhere bro goes hey
1957 you were standing in a dude he's
standing behind the [ __ ] group with
just white you know everybody looks the
same what was it about what it was about
he wasn't he was in Little Rock Arkansas
pull it up it was uh it was when the the
desegregation the desegregation they
were they were trying to Black just
block these black kids trying to get
into the school like look at look at the
front Jerry Jones bro if you could zoom
in Jerry Jones is in the back bro
standing right there can we just
acknowledge like everybody had great
hair back
I'm like [ __ ] Pomade and things poor
Malik is looking at him yeah
but like look at this hair it's stunning
right and my mind like like it was a gel
was it what is going on but yo do you
see like do you like think about uh
Andrew and he's just chilling bro
this cigarette does not like black
people that was for sure
this ain't even lit
but like so you imagine like my question
was like those people they could dig up
and they could find so this has been a
this has been out since 1957. and then
somebody goes oh you know what watch
this Jerry Jones right there in the back
and mind you he's just in the wrong
place at the wrong time just standing
what if it's in the back I mean did he
say he was protesting there's no like
video here's did you see his answer or
no what is it he says I didn't even know
why I was there I was 15. yeah I was
scared I was gonna get in trouble I have
no other memories outside of that I just
showed up so that's what he said yeah
Stephen A Smith said he should have said
I heard there was black girls coming to
school you know what I'm saying I was
trying to step in the truck
stop listening I'm trying to try new
things
that would have been funny if he did say
something like that just mess with him
no I was I was dating this girl Kiki and
you know we were like she's on the other
side you don't see her
Kiki what's on the other side telling me
come on come on Cherry oh my God no
Stephen A said originally he says come
on guys you're doing this you're
bringing back back a picture from 60
some years ago when the man was 15 years
old leave this one alone what are you
doing anyways then LeBron today says I'm
wondering how come you guys are asking
all these questions about Kyrie but you
guys are not losing it over what Jerry
Jones said or Jerry Jones's pictures how
come you're not that uh energetic about
that and that's how LeBron was kind of a
uh and then Stephen A came back and said
I one thousand percent agree with what
LeBron said today anyways it's a mess
with a guy 65 years you got a good point
if they want to come after you and
Target you on anything it's not going to
be hard to find anything on anybody
nowadays oh I'm screwed especially my
military days I did some outlandish [ __ ]
drone strikes not that crazy but
not that one uh no I'm just talking
about pictures and Nick I dude I there's
[ __ ] out there of me or if they ever
want to bro like they'll just poop and
they got you yeah you just don't run for
a public off never so what all the
craziness taking place I believe future
looks right if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of valuetainment it says
future looks bright here future looks
bright here we got them in white we got
them in Black we got them in red are
black on black sold out these are about
to sell out if you haven't ordered one
yet we had a person in Michigan but one
then he bought three then when those
three people wore it in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody saying future looks
bright toward your future looks bright
hat click over here and to watch the
entire podcast click here take care
everybody
[Music]